Islandia es uno de los países más aislados
del mundo.
La costa más cercana a Islandia es la de
Escocia… y está a 1233 kilómetros de distancia.
Sin embargo, cada año lo visitan cerca de
2.3 millones de turistas, es decir más de
6 veces su población.
Hace 13 años sufrieron una crisis que devastó
el sistema financiero y ahora son uno de los
países más ricos del mundo.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo salieron de esta crisis?
¿Y cómo es posible que sean tan ricos?
¿Qué producen en este país para tener tanto
dinero?
En este vídeo te lo vamos a contar.
Islandia es un país tan aislado y pequeño
que hasta tienen una app para ligar en bares
y asegurarse de que la persona con la que
están flirteando no es un familiar cercano.
Un tipo de Tinder Islandés en el que debes
verificar si la niña que conociste en el
bar anoche no es tu prima.
Este país es una isla al noroeste de Europa,
en el que literalmente puedes nadar entre
dos placas tectónicas, y tiene poco más
de 350,000 habitantes.
Es decir, para daros una idea, esto es menos
habitantes que una ciudad como Murcia.
Islandia es alimentada prácticamente en su
totalidad por energías renovables.
Son conocidos por sus volcanes o por la música
de Björk, y la verdad es que este es un país
muy peculiar, por ejemplo, no existe un McDonald’s,
y la cerveza se prohibió hasta 1989.
¡Vamos!
Estoy seguro de que muchos de los que os estáis
viendo hubieran huido de ahí con estos datos.
Además de todo esto, Islandia tiene una gran
cualidad, y es que es muy rico, y aquí viene
una pregunta que seguro muchos estáis pensando
¿Y cómo lo ha hecho ese país tan aislado?
Pues esto lo responderemos más adelante.
Pero pese a estar tan aislado, como os hemos
dicho, es uno de los países más ricos y
modernos del mundo.
En términos de PIB per cápita, los islandeses
son más ricos que los singapurenses, los
estadounidenses o incluso los daneses.
Además, este país cuenta con una distribución
de riqueza envidiable y es el sexto país
con el índice de desarrollo humano más alto
del mundo.
Sin embargo, si Islandia es famosa por algo
es por la crisis financiera.
Quizás fue el país más afectado por la
crisis de 2008.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo puede ser que un
país tan aislado y tan pequeño esté tan
afectado por una crisis internacional?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Qué hicieron
para salir de esa crisis y crecer a ritmos
de más del 4% anual?
Pues atentos.
Islandia: la exitosa fórmula del país que
no rescató a sus bancos pero salvó su economía
BBC 16-03-2017
Así es, este país no rescató a sus banqueros.
De hecho, esta es una de las razones por las
que, durante un tiempo, Islandia era el supermodelo
de la izquierda anticapitalista.
El bastión contra el neoliberalismo.
Pero, como vais a ver en este vídeo, la historia
no es tan simple.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué Islandia
es tan rica?
¿Y cómo salieron de la crisis?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes… antes os tengo que recomendar
un nuevo canal de YouTube en el que colabora
VisualPolitik.
Hablamos de “Si lo Hubiera Sabido”, el
nuevo canal de actualidad financiera creado
por Mutuactivos.
En este canal vais a descubrir todas las tendencias
más importantes que mueven las finanzas ¿Puede
ser rentable invertir en empresas sostenibles?
¿Cómo podemos usar la bolsa para proteger
nuestros ahorros de la inflación?
¿Cómo se está comportando el mercado de
valores en la salida de la pandemia?
Todas estas son preguntas a las que se responden
en este canal.
Todo ello sin clickbait, sin sensacionalismo
y con muchísimo rigor.
Os dejo el link en la descripción.
Y ahora sí… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA LIBERACIÓN DEL PULPO
Durante décadas, la economía islandesa estuvo
llamada por el llamado “PULPO”.
Y diréis ¿A qué pulpo nos referimos?
Pues no, no nos referimos al animal.
“El Pulpo” es como se conoce en Islandia
a las catorce familias que controlaron toda
la economía y la política del país hasta
finales del siglo 20.
Incluso los suministros de la base que tiene
la OTAN en este país estaban controlados
por una de estas familias.
Por aquel entonces, la principal industria
islandesa era la pesca.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, toda ese sector
esta controlado bien por empresas estatales,
dirigidas por miembros de El Pulpo o bien
empresas privadas propiedad de El Pulpo y
subvencionadas por el Gobierno.
Sin embargo, todo cambió con la llegada de
este hombre.
Este señor que veis en pantalla es DAVID
ODDSON: primer ministro de Islandia entre
1991 y 2004.
El señor Oddson es el responsable de la privatización
de todo el sector pesquero y las grandes bajadas
de impuestos.
Bajo su gobierno, el impuesto de sociedades
en Islandia pasó del 48% al 18%.
También eliminó todos casi todos los subsidios
a sectores no productivos y hizo todo lo posible
por diversificar la economía de Islandia.
Tan sólo 3 años más tarde de que Oddson
llegara al Gobierno, en 1994, Islandia ya
entraba en el Espacio Económico Europeo.
Y así es como comenzó el milagro económico
islandés.
Desde 2003 hasta 2008, este país creció
a una media anual del 6,4%.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esas cifras
son propias de un país emergente.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
¿De verdad bastó con liberalizar la economía
para que Islandia se convirtiera en un oasis
de progreso?
Pues aquí llega la cara B del milagro islandés.
La liberalización financiera provocó que
Islandia se convirtiera en un paraíso para
inversión extranjera.
Las medidas de Oddson, lograron dar confianza
al mercado internacional para que los bancos
de Islandia tuvieran mucho poder, pasando
de ese país pesquero y convencional, a todo
un monstruo financiero.
Y ¿Qué problema puede ser darle tanto poder
a los bancos?
La respuesta es que puede ser un colapso,
entonces aquí se desató la crisis de niveles
Nachovidalianas, ojo con esto:
El colapso del Sistema financiero Islandés
se acelera
New York Times 09-10-2008
¿Por qué?
¿Qué fue lo que provocó todo este colapso?
Pues atentos:
EL PAÍS QUE DIJO NO A LOS RESCATES
En 2007, Islandia era el sexto país más
rico de todo el planeta.
Sin embargo, un año más tarde tuvieron que
pedir ayuda al Fondo Monetario Internacional.
¿Cómo llegaron a este extremo tan rápido?
Pues todo empezó porque en pocos años pasó
de ser un país conocido por la pesca, plantas
hidroeléctricas y volcanes, a ser todo un
centro financiero.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2008,
una familia promedio islandesa era tres veces
más rica que en 2003.
Pese a no tener McDonald´s Islandia tiene
la mayor concentración de campos de Golf
per capita del mundo.
Pero ¿Qué había detrás de todo este crecimiento?
Pues atentos.
En 2008, los 3 principales bancos de Islandia
tenían de valor en activos casi 11 veces
el PIB del país, eso es como si JP Morgan,
Bank of America y Wells Fargo fueran 33 veces
mayor de lo que son hoy en día.
Estos bancos comenzaron a atraer inversiones
de todo el mundo, primero por la alta calificación
del país, y segundo, por las altas tasas
de interés que sus bancos pagaban a los inversores.
Y ese dinero se usaba principalmente para
prestar y hacer inversiones en otros países
europeos.
¿Conclusión?
En 2008, estos bancos islandeses tenían una
deuda de 8 veces mayor que todo el país.
Mientras todas las inversiones que hacían
en el resto de Europa daban retornos, no había
ningún problema.
De hecho, entre 2003 2008, la corona islandesa
duplicó su valor.
Es decir, que no sólo los islandeses ganaban
más dinero sino que, además, ese dinero
valía cada vez más ¡No sólo eso!
Como los bancos islandeses recibían dinero
de todo el mundo, los ciudadanos islandeses
conseguían créditos con enorme facilidad.
De hecho, lo normal por estos lares era refinanciar
las deudas hasta la extenuación.
Y así es como Islandia, un país del tamaño
de Murcia, se convirtió en un sistema financiero
atado a un país.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasó para que todo
este sistema colapsara?
¿Cuál fue el punto de inflexión?
Pues este.
Wall Street cae tras la quiebra de Lehman
Brothers y la venta de Merrill Lynch
El Economista 15-09-2008
¡Exacto!
En el año 2008 estalló la crisis financiera
en todo el mundo.
Y eso tuvo consecuencias bestiales para Islandia.
La quiebra de bancos desató un pánico en
los mercados.
Los bancos europeos dejaron de prestar en
Islandia por el riesgo que esto representaba
y también le recortaron calificaciones.
Los bancos islandeses reaccionaron subiendo
la tasa de interés hasta 15.5% para evitar
la fuga de capitales.
Pero esto no sirvió de nada por que el banco
central solo controlaba una pequeña parte
de lo que se prestaba.
Debido a la crisis los activos de los bancos
que llegaron a valer 11 veces el PIB de Islandia
ya valían mucho menos.
Y las deudas que valían 8 veces el PIB de
todo el país ya no se pudieron refinanciar.
Dicho de otra forma, los bancos islandeses
tenían que pagar un montón de dinero…
mucho más de lo que había en todo el país.
Y eso sumió a Islandia en la bancarrota más
absoluta.
Los bancos tuvieron que liquidar sus activos
en la divisa islandesa, la corona, para devolver
préstamos al extranjero ¿El problema?
Que la salida masiva de capitales hizo que
el precio de la corona se hundiera.
Dicho de otra forma: en sólo 3 días, todo
el sector bancario islandés colapsó.
Y ahí es cuando el Gobierno tuvo que pedir
un préstamo al Fondo Monetario Internacional.
Y os preguntareis, con tantos problemas y
toda Europa echando mano de ellos ¿Por qué
no quisieron integrarse a la Unión Europea?
Pues, de hecho, Islandia presentó una solicitud
para unirse a la Unión Europea en 2009.
Sin embargo, a finales de 2012, Islandia ya
se había recuperado de la crisis.
La divisa islandesa ya se había recuperado.
Así que los islandeses se pensaron dos veces
eso de entrar en el EURO y la Unión Europea.
Y ya sé lo que os preguntaréis ahora…
¿Pero cómo pudieron salir de esa crisis
de una forma tan milagrosa?
Seguramente muchos creáis que sabéis la
respuesta.
Y esto es así porque, durante mucho tiempo,
el caso islandés llenó portadas de periódicos
con titulares como este.
Islandia: el éxito de dejar caer a la banca
y no salvarla con dinero del contribuyente
El Economista 02-02-2020
Habéis oído bien: Islandia se convirtió
en todo un símbolo de la lucha contra los
malvados bancos que provocaron la crisis.
Y sí, es cierto que Islandia fue uno de los
pocos países que no rescató a sus bancos.
Ahora bien, la historia es muy distinta de
la leyenda ¿Recordáis que antes hemos dicho
que Islandia pidió un préstamo al Fondo
Monetario Internacional?
Hablamos de un préstamo de más de 2.000
millones de dólares ¿Y para qué creéis
que sirvió ese dinero?
Pues precisamente para garantizar los depósitos
que los ahorradores islandeses tenían en
los bancos.
Básicamente, el Gobierno de Islandia nacionalizó
a sus tres principales bancos con el dinero
del FMI y otros bancos centrales.
Por supuesto, la mayor parte de ese dinero
que habían puesto los inversores internacionales
se perdió.
Pero no es del todo correcto decir que Islandia
dejó caer a sus bancos.
Y tampoco es justo decir que Islandia se saltara
la ortodoxia económica.
Al contrario.
En el año 2015, Islandia ya había liquidado
prácticamente todas las deudas con el FMI.
Y la nacionalización de la banca fue una
medida de emergencia.
Algo que se puso en marcha para evitar que
los ahorradores perdieran dinero.
De hecho, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo, Islandia ha terminado de resolver
todos sus problemas financieros.
Y por eso, en este año 2021 nos encontramos
con noticias como esta.
Islandia Lanza la privatización del banco
estatal Islandbanski
Financial Times 27-05-2021
¡Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
en este momento!
¿Pero de dónde sacaron todo el dinero para
poder devolver los préstamos?
¿Cómo fueron capaces de salir de la crisis
de una forma tan milagrosa?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
CANCIÓN DE HIELO Y FUEGO
Si hay algo que ha hecho a Islandia archi
conocida en todo el mundo es Juego de Tronos.
Como seguramente sabréis muchos, Islandia
fue el escenario de muchísimas escenas de
esta serie.
Pues bien, el hecho de que esta serie se grabara
en Islandia tiene mucho que ver con nuestra
historia.
Básicamente, tras el cataclismo de 2008,
los islandeses se dieron cuenta de que sólo
había una forma de salir adelante.
Y no, no tenía nada que ver con ingeniería
financiera, ni maquillaje de cuentas públicas.
La única solución para volver a ser crear
riqueza es permitiendo que surjan nuevos sectores
económicos ¿Y qué ventajas tiene Islandia
que no tengan otros lugares?
Pues, entre otras muchas cosas, Islandia tiene
un paisaje único en el mundo.
Casi parece de otro planeta.
Y eso es una oportunidad para hacer negocios
como este.
Cómo Islandia se convirtió en el escenario
perfecto para las películas de ciencia ficción
de Hollywood
Little White Lies 12-06-2018
¡Habéis oído bien!
Desde el año 2008, Islandia se ha convertido
en escenario de las superproducciones de Hollywood.
Desde los pasos de Jon Snow en Juego de Tronos
hasta varias escenas de Star Wars.
El cine se ha convertido en algo tan importante
en este país que en 2018 se han llegado a
abrir enormes estudios de grabación.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
¿De qué otras maneras se puede monetizar
un paisaje tan único en el mundo?
Pues atentos.
El turismo continúa siendo el principal motor
del crecimiento: el 47% de los nuevos trabajos
creados en los últimos 12 meses viene del
turismo
Iceland Mag 11-04-2017
Seguro que muchos de vosotros habréis visitado
Islandia en los últimos años.
Y, si no, tendréis algún amigo que lo ha
hecho.
Y no es casualidad.
Hasta los años 2000, sólo algunos mochileros
se atrevían con este país.
Pero, desde el año 2009, el turismo en Islandia
se ha disparado.
Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver cómo el turismo en Islandia
ha despegado tras la crisis.
De hecho, antes de la pandemia del CoronaVirus,
Islandia llegó a superar los 2 millones de
turistas al año.
Esto es casi 5 veces la población total del
país.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
¿Cómo han reaccionado al coronavirus?
A fin de cuentas… si hay una industria castigada
por la pandemia, esa es el turismo.
Pues lo cierto es que Islandia está explotando
muchas cosas aparte de su paisaje.
Al devaluarse la moneda local, los bienes
y servicios islandeses se hicieron más baratos
para los extranjeros.
Principalmente uno: el aluminio.
Atentos a esta otra gráfica.
Como podéis ver, Islandia no ha perdido el
tiempo.
Tan pronto como estalló la crisis, el país
se puso a exportar aluminio como si no hubiera
mañana.
Este país puede ser casi un microestado,
pero está entre los 10 productores de aluminio
del mundo.
Cada año exportan unas 840.000 toneladas
de aluminio.
A todo esto hay que sumarle otra importación
típicamente islandesa: el pescado.
De nuevo, hablamos de otro sector que se ha
disparado tras la crisis de 2008.
Pensadlo bien: sólo con el turismo, la pesca
y el aluminio, Islandia podría haber salido
bien parada de la crisis.
A fin de cuentas, estos tres sectores se caracterizan
por dar trabajo a muchísima gente.
Todo esto serviría para explicar cómo Islandia
atajó todos sus problemas de desempleo derivados
por la crisis.
Pero la economía de este país es toda una
caja de sorpresas.
Cómo Islandia se convirtió en un paraíso
de los mineros de BitCoin
The Guardian 13-02-2018
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
seguramente ya conoceréis la historia con
todos los detalles.
Hemos hablado de ella hace poco en un vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción.
Pero lo cierto es que el sector tecnológico
en Islandia va mucho más allá de las criptodivisas.
Veréis, si un día queréis montar un servidor
en Internet o un centro de datos, hay una
cosa muy importante que vais a necesitar:
energía.
Energía para poder refrigerar todos los miles
de discos duros que están en funcionamiento
las 24 horas del día.
En este respecto, Islandia ofrece un aspecto
fundamental: energía verde y absurdamente
barata.
Casi toda la energía en este país viene
de la hiper actividad térmica que tiene la
isla.
Recordad que esté entre dos fallas gigantescas.
Así que los islandeses disfrutan de una factura
de la luz muy pero que muy barata.
Y eso ha disparado toda clase de empresas
muy tecnológicas ¿Qué decís?
¿Qué no conocéis ninguna empresa tecnológica
en Islandia?
Pues atentos
El monument al EVE Online de Islandia homenajea
a los jugadores inmortalizando sus nombres
Polygon 01-05-2014
¡Habeís oído bien!
Por si alguno no lo conoce, el EVE online
es uno de los juegos online más complejos
que existen.
Es algo así como un mundo paralelo de ciencia
ficción.
Más de 300.000 personas juegan a él todos
los meses.
Y podríamos decir que existe toda una subcultura
en torno al EVE.
De hecho, es un juego que parece hecho para
fanáticos de la política.
Así que no me extrañaría que muchos de
vosotros seáis auténticos fans de este juego.
Pues bien, la empresa detrás de este juego
nació en Islandia y tiene sus principales
estudios en REJKIAVIC.
Dicho de otra forma: que para ser un país
tan pequeño, existe un sector tecnológico
nada desdeñable.
Y todo esto explica por qué, en los últimos
años, Islandia no sólo sea un país rico.
Es que además ha seguido creciendo a ritmos
de más del 4% interanual.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿De
verdad creéis que Islandia va a ser capaz
de mantener este crecimiento?
¿O volveremos a ver otra crisis en este país?
¿Podrán remontar el sector turístico tras
el coronavirus?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, recordad visitar “Si lo
hubiera Sabido” el nuevo canal de finanzas
en el que colabora VisualPolitik.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que en este canal
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.